Although I did see this amazing
video of Buzz Aldrin to do seedless
punching the guy go to, I know that
guy that he punched. I want to,
I want to do more moon landing tonight
mean I know you know Alex Jones.
I used to be a moon landing denier.
I used to believe,
I used to believe totally that we never
went to the moon because there was a
document of the came
on Fox. Yes, trust me,
I didn't Google the nineties in the
1990s Fox had a show called conspiracy
theory.
Did we go to the moon and they aired it
on television prime time and they got me
hook, line and sinker, and for years I
believe that we didn't go to the moon.
What changed you?
Mostly talking to Neil degrasse Tyson,
but also critical thinking.
Also realizing that I was fully committed
to that idea without really exploring
the possibility whether that idea was
incorrect and that I had taken everything
that I saw in that documentary,
which is incredibly convincing
and with a 100% confirmation bias.
I only looked at that and I didn't
look at all the contrary evidence.
There's some fucked up stuff about
the moon landing unfortunately.
And the fucked up stuff is mostly people
that were involved in publicity that
we're doing stupid things
with photographs. Like they
had taken a picture of 'em
I'm going into unchartered
territory or just so you know,
like you're an expert on this. I've never
gone into moon landing. Denialism yeah,
I don't know about it.
Uh, it was buzz Aldrin. Um,
who was the guy that was Michael Collins?
Michael Collins in Gemini 15 photographs.
He seen it many times. Pulled
up that photo. This is,
and this is what I'm talking about. No,
no, no. It has nothing to do with that.
This is a photo that they,
um,
they put out as an official photograph
of Michael Collins doing a spacewalk.
But what it actually is,
is a photo of them testing equipment
and they blacked out the background.
So he's in this suit that they were
doing with testing and instead,
because they really couldn't get good
photos in space cause no one's out there
with him taking his pictures.
Right. So they lied, they
faked it. This is it. So the,
see the one on the left,
you see the real photograph and this is
him in a studio where they're working on
him try or warehouse rather or some sort
of a testing environment working on how
to,
uh,
control these harnesses that you would
use when you were on a space walk.
Cause that thing,
you know,
propels him forward and back
and he's learning how to use it.
What they did was they just blacked out
the background and reversed it and then
they sold that as him
actually being in space.
So this is probably an overzealous
publicist and there's a bunch of these,
there's a bunch of these when it comes
to, um, different backgrounds in,
in areas of the moon. There are many,
many miles apart from each other.
It shouldn't be the same background and
more likely than not what you're dealing
with is overzealous publicists because
photographs were incredibly difficult to
get.
I'm sure.
Well, the moral of this story
to me, thank God, first of all,
that you're no longer
a moon landing denier,
but also the power of the media and the
press and like you saw one documentary,
right? Was a couple after I
saw that and not quite a few,
but that sent you down
this rabbit hole and that.